[Musique]
après une première semaine de tournage
sur transporteur je suis avec Jason
Statham au cinéma pour voir ce film pour
nous changer les idées on s'est pris une
claque de ciné on a dit ce qu'on a envie
de faire mec
et puis bon lui il a commencé à faire du
Fast and Furious bien avant moi et
j'étais un peu jaloux
oui enfin c'était surtout très amusant
et excitant de voir et c'était on était
comme deux copains qui se retrouvent qui
se fonde juste des
onomatopées pendant 2 minutes et tout le
monde genre regarder genre qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont ces deux
frères
de ça parce que on a entendu les
histoires je me suis dit
tu sors tu sors de de l'avion tu arrives
direction le plateau et je dis ce que je
peux aller rencontrer vin il tournait
pas ce jour-là et il était là sur le
plateau et tout le temps là et donc je
vais à vincamps c'est enfin c'est de
c'est c'est deux caravanes avec une
barrière et le vincampe avec vinyworld
appelle ça et tu as des gardes du corps
dans la tête trois barrières à passer
c'est donc tu rentres t'attends bonjour
C'est qui bonjour je suis lourd le
nouveau réalisateur
attendez ici
ok c'est bon tu passes à la deuxième
partie bonjour vous êtes Louis le
terrier on vous a pas dit non vous êtes
qui je suis réalisateur nouveau
pour ta tu fais 10 mètres en 5 minutes
et quand j'arrive mes deux mais comme
dans un film de dos rasé tu vois comme
ça les muscles Marcel supramé en tout
cas les muscles et ils se retournent
bienvenue mon frère et toi on se fait un
gros HUG et on a passé 5 heures ensemble
on a passé toute la journée à se parler
alors que j'allais tourner je faisais
aller-retours il faut que j'attende un
plan et je revenais on continue à parler
vraiment c'est immédiatement
et adoré mais immédiatement et et c'est
vraiment une histoire d'amitié qui qui
continue encore aujourd'hui enfin on
s'appelle tout le temps toute la nuit
était à Rome ouais non je suis pas
encore là je suis à Paris ouais
j'aimerais bien trouver on j'adore ce
mec là vraiment c'est très très bien
entendu mais
déjà bon j'étais pas du tout au courant
de ce qui se passait donc les personnes
le savez j'ai reçu j'ai reçu un appel
c'est vraiment surpris j'ai pas décroché
c'est pour te dire à quel point j'étais
surpris quand je pensais que c'était une
erreur que que c'est quand même le
patron de lumière salle qui m'appelle je
veux son numéro je t'appelais mais une
fois tous les quatre ans pour se
proposer un truc et là il était minuit
je lui dis non non c'est une erreur donc
je lui envoie un texto en lui disant à
Peter tu as du fait du faire une erreur
à bientôt passe une bonne nuit et me
dire non non est-ce que tu m'as appelé
tout de suite j'étais en finition d'un
truc j'étais en train de faire un double
doublage d'un film justement que j'étais
en train de faire avec Omar et et
Omar Sy et Laurent Lafitte je dis aux
garçons d'attendre je vais prendre le
coup de fil et il m'explique et il me
dit est-ce que tu peux lire le scénario
je dis ouais oui oui oui et ce que tu
veux faire un rendez-vous à 5h du matin
et c'est quand même minuit donc j'ai
j'ai passé une nuit un peu courte à lire
et relire et j'adorais le Sénat le
scénarité génial et prendre ce premier
appel ce premier zoom j'ai eu un peu
peur en fait j'ai eu j'ai eu peur de de
pas pouvoir enfin c'est compliqué de de
aucun réalisateur
qui qui se qui connaît un peu le métier
n'accepte de prendre un film au rebond
et tout de suite et surtout que on peut
pas s'arrêter parce que les acteurs
avaient des stops il fallait vraiment
prendre l'avion à se poser et dire
action ah ouais mais c'était ça c'était
donc j'aurais dit je suis pas sûr je
suis pas sûr ouais on comprend et tout
bon réfléchit réfléchis et je suis
arrivé dans dans ma chambre ma femme
était un mal à l'ouvre un œil pour elle
avait la grippe elle dit ça va tu as
l'air un peu pâle tu as la grippe je dis
non non j'ai pas dormi j'ai pas dormi ah
bon qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on m'a
proposé Fast and Furious 1 quoi le
deuxième oeil s'ouvre quoi je dis ouais
ouais et puis je pense pas que je peux
le faire et alors là tout de suite mais
elle s'est levée
42 fier tu vas le faire c'est ton rêve
fais-le et elle et j'ai dit d'accord ok
je vais les rappeler genre un texto
bonbon je réfléchi faisons un autre
appel à 8h donc je fais un autre appel
Charlie j'aurais expliqué ce que je
pensais
mes idées et dans zoom parce que un
autre etc jusqu'au ces deux jours de
rendez-vous et de et c'était drôle parce
que c'est un peu j'avais pas le film
mais j'avais le film on me disait oui et
si tu venais tu veux quoi comme hôtel et
si tu dis merde
c'est comme dans les Lucky Luke quand
elle croque-mort
es
[Musique]